as we look out over most of the valley
though we have got blue skies and air
quality overall will be good today
except for elevated ozone because of the
heat when we talk about smoke in the air
quality report we're talking about
wildfire smoke and we don't see much of
that making its way into our area today
we've got a mix of 70s and 80s
very dry air out there and that started
really drying out over the weekend you
know we had those pop-up thunderstorms
on friday that brought some rain some
really strong winds and lightning for a
few hours friday afternoon but we
recovered nicely through the weekend 104
today just like sunday our normal high
is 95 so we're going to be well above
normal sunrise was 6 22 6 50 the sunset
breezy winds thanks to this cold front
up north texas dealing with tropical
storm nicholas with lots of rain no rain
for us just lots of dry air and gusty
winds fire weather warnings start before
noon today any fires that break out are
going to have a tough time in the wind
thankfully we don't have that wind this
morning but they'll be up to 30 miles an
hour this afternoon and excessive heat
warnings continue for the lake and the
river until this evening 104 today keep
yourself hydrated keep yourself cool it
is going to be another hot one 102
without as many breezes tomorrow we stay
hot for the first half of the week still
hot at 99 thursday but those temps slide
into more normal mid 90s for the weekend
mornings will be delightful we'll cool
off to the 60's